hello everyone and welcome to a
brilliant brilliant attacking game that
was played on chess.com it's a
three-minute blitz game between
international master yakov norovitz and
the grand master daniel naroditsuki it
comes as a suggestion from user
americans so thank you for suggesting
such a such a wonderful attacking game
and before the start of the of the grand
prix we have a time to cover a few fun
games such as this uh so let's dive
straight into it features the uh very
interesting tatakova defense and um i i
have a feeling that after this game you
guys might be trying it out as well uh
so let's check it out uh in order it's
with the white pieces opens with d4 we
have knight to f6 uh knight to f3 and
now d6 this is the tactical defense with
e3 and the g6 now preparing for the
fiance to the dark square bishop uh
bishop to e2 and now bishop to g7 uh and
now both players just castle so castles
castles and now b3
white wants to develop the bishop to b2
and counter black's very strong bishop
on g7 so c6
gaining more control of the center also
clearing the c7 square for the black
queen and then we will fight for the e5
square so here at bishop b2 we have
queen to c7 and now c4 white also grabs
a lot of space in the center here knight
beat the d7 adding another attacker of
the e5 square and not knight to c3 and
finally uh narditsky strikes with e5 we
have queen to c2 this is best left
ignored adjusted the continued
developing connector rooks developed the
queen
rook to e8 and now rook ate the c1 now
you still have to develop the rook on f1
but black decides that now is the time
to strike with e captures on d4
and this is very useful uh because if
white captures with the pawn then we're
gonna move the knight and we have this
excellent f5 square to develop our
bishop the queen is on c2 so this is
going to be very nice so white decides
to capture with the knight on the e4 but
now now you have no control over the c5
square so knight to c5 uh very nice
square for this knight and now rook
after d1 the the position is a known one
rook c to d1 is a non-move bishop to f3
is a normal but rook after d1 is a new
move so now as of move 13 we have a
completely new game uh we have a5 uh
makes sense you do not want to allow b4
as you really like your knight on c5
queen to b1
and now a4 uh pushing uh pushing that
pawn now saying okay you push your b for
pawn i don't mind this is exactly what
um uh norwich does and now comes a3
attacking the bishop here bishop back to
a1 and knight to e6 and this is a sort
of a critical moment in the game where
white uh can uh decides to to fight for
advantage if he plays knight to d5 and
the game becomes very very interesting
point is that if captures captures you
open up the attack towards the queen and
you will also win back your piece so
that's not an issue we would see
something like queen d8 and after
something like captures we're going to
see bishop captures knight at the knight
goes to f4 attacks the bishop and the
white has some pressure
but like i said this is a three-minute
blitz game so white uh doesn't have all
that much time to calculate the uh
knight back to b3 and now uh we have uh
knight to g5 so just uh bringing your
pieces closer and closer to the enemy
king that's how you should always play
we have c5 now going after that d6 pawn
and of course pawn to d5 and now knight
to d4
uh so what do you play here well bishop
to g4
and this is again a very interesting
position because you should just ignore
what black is doing of course in a
three-minute blizz game that's easier
said than done you should play some like
b5 and then uh you know the game just
continues you say you've got nothing
here however here white started
defending against non-existent threats
or rather white started seeing ghosts
and he played h3 he wanted the situation
on the king sides to be resolved
immediately and then he's gonna start
playing on the queen side but this
allows black to just uh perform a very
crushing attack here bishop captures on
h3 was played g captures and now not
even knight captures an h3 with check
but even uh
a crazy remove rook captures on e3 uh
crucial stuff here because you want to
free up the g3 square for the queen so
if pawn captures rook that's pretty much
it and the other uh
fun thing about rook to e3 even if you
play some like king g2 to defend the h3
pawn now that's not uh possible you're
just going to be able to capture the
pawn with the rook as the knight also
defends it so white doesn't really have
a move here f captures an e3 was played
but now queen the g3 check king h1 we
also pick up the pawn with check queen
captures an h3 with king g1 queen g3
check king the h1 and now rook to e8
preparing uh
well just bringing another another piece
into the attack and white is lost it's
only a matter of how you want to lose
rook to d3 was played and now it's
actually a forced mate in eight uh for
for black but uh only the first movie is
the move that matters so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
quickest way to victory while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
you can threaten mate in one and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is rook to e4 after all that
black sacrificed he uh
tries to give up another rook and you
kind of have to capture it because rook
to h4 will be checkmated there's no
defense here so the knight has to be
captured as it was in the game now comes
knight f captures an e4 now the threat
being knight to f2 checkmate the queen
is completely boxing the white king in
so knight to f2 will be game over so
rook to f1 defending the f2 square but
now just bishop to e5 and he was in this
position on move 28 that jakub norvitz
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so really a
spectacular spectacular game uh
everything about it was super enjoyable
after that h3 move white's position just
completely uh you know uh got
obliterated now the thing is after
knight f3 okay you could guard the h2
square but we're just gonna capture it
and that's it there's nothing you can do
if bishop captures an e5 we can still
play queen h3 check and after you block
this as there's no other move queen
captures and h2 will be checkmate so
let's just uh see this like a a
perfectly normal position where you can
just continue playing queen d3 can be
played b5 can be played a lot a lot of
moves can be played here but after h3
such an innocent looking move and
everything just uh falls apart first the
bishop then the rook uh and then uh of
course the other rook is also sacrificed
and then well just uh bishop e5 and game
over there's no way to defend rook f2 of
course impossible queen to h2 is just
over so beautiful stuff by narodicy as
usual he's one of the i believe one of
the strongest attacking players with the
black pieces in the world uh i don't
think in in shorter time formats i don't
think there's anyone he can't defeat and
in even quicker time formats than three
plus oh for example in bullet and even
faster i think uh you know with the
black pieces he he can do stuff like
this the the to the likes of magnus and
the other you know uh legendary players
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it of course uh always keep
recommending me uh such games as they
are you know
these are the kind of attacking games
that belong in books uh even though
they're blitz games you know you can
still learn a lot from them uh i would
like to thank nagarjuna ponogoti gm
sucks rocks the original scock-o-matic
the evans gambit for being winning and
ken scott for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the chess world
the grand prix is starting very soon so
we are going to cover that uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day